This week in history, in the year 1457,
we remember one of Christendom's
greatest yet least known defenders
against Islamic aggression, George
Castrioti of Albania, better known as
Scanderbegg. Our story begins four
decades earlier when George was taken
captive as a 9-year-old child by the
Ottoman Turks and trained to be a
janisary, that is, a Christian slave,
forcibly turned into becoming a Muslim
soldier. Excelling at war, he quickly
rose among the Ottoman ranks until he
became a renowned general with thousands
of Turks under his command. Despite all
the honors showered on him once the
opportunity appeared years later, he
showed where his true allegiance lay. He
broke free of the Ottomans and fled to
his native and continuously harried
Albania. Thereafter, after openly
reclaiming his Christian faith, he quote
renounced the prophet and the sultan and
proclaimed himself the avenger of his
family and his country to quote Edward
Gibbon. Thereafter, from 1443 to 1468, a
quarter of a century, Scanderbeg
committed his life to the successful
defense of his tiny homeland against the
world's most powerful empire. In so
doing, he renounced a life of wealth,
prestige, and untold pleasures among the
Ottomans, and willingly embraced a life
of non-stop war on behalf of his own
people, often living in mountains and
caves as a fugitive, though always
living in freedom. His ingratitude
naturally provoked the Turks to no end
and prompted wave after wave of jihadist
invasions, each larger and cruer than
its predecessor. Yet in a total of 24
battles and sieges, he beat them all
back. Always while being vastly
outnumbered by his Muslim foes, often 10
to1. Little wonder he is known as the
Albanian Braveheart. Arguably his
greatest victory came in 1450 when
Sultan Morad II himself led a gargantuan
army of 160,000 men into Albania,
straight for Scanderbeck's stronghold,
the White Castle of Croya, which the
Sultan put to siege on May 14th. Day
after day, Ottoman cannons rocked the
White Castle with projectiles weighing
as much as 400 lb. Although Scanderbe
only had 18,000 Christian defenders, he
performed remarkable deeds to quote a
contemporary. Meanwhile, the Janiseries,
the traitors to God and their country,
the worms whose conscience is ever
tormenting their souls, to quote the
former Janisary, Scanderbe, terrorized
and devastated the land of their former
brother in arms, burning homes and grain
fields. Several Albanian nobles
individually surrendered in the hopes of
retaining their lands and titles. Others
envious of Scanderbegg actively welcomed
the Turks in the hopes of breaking his
influence. And Venice once again
supplied the Islamic invader. Despite
such odds and by all accounts,
Scanderbegg and his men inside and
outside of Croya fought tooth and nail
and managed to inflict heavy casualties
on their enemies who outnumbered them by
nearly 10 to one. In the words of a 19th
century historian, quote, "With
matchless strategy, he contrived to keep
the myriads of his opponents from the
walls. With energy almost superhuman, he
swept unexpectedly, now here and now
there, by night and by day, into the
midst of the foe. Every swordsman of his
band heweed down scores of the enemy,
and his own blade flashed as the
lightning and caused Muslim heads to
fall like snowflakes where he passed.
Thousands of the bravest warriors of
Morad were thus swept away continuously.
His hosts were diminishing to the point
of danger to his very person. At his
wit's end, Marad at one point quote
retired to his pavilion, overcome with
grief and rage, tearing his hair in his
beard and pouring out blasphemous
speeches against the majesty of heaven,
seeming to call the Almighty in question
for suffering his gray hairs and his
former glory and the Ottoman name to be
disgraced and humbled for the sake of a
poultry castle in Albania.
As might be expected, contemporary
Ottoman chronicles are more sparing.
They write, quote, "Marrage and his army
struck Croya with cannons and turned it
into a graveyard. He hoped that they
would surrender, but they did not.
Winter then arrived,
and that was that." Having marched one
of the largest armies he had ever
mustered, and having invested Croya for
8 months, Morad resigned and lifted the
siege. Some 20,000 Muslims had been
killed for nothing. Although Albania was
devastated and plagued by starvation,
that Christmas was the happiest the
people ever enjoyed, wrote a chronicler.
Now, if Croya showcased Scanderbegg's
defensive genius, the later battle of
Albuena, which occurred this week in
history on September 2nd, represented
the pinnacle of his offensive daring. In
late May 1457, 80,000 Turks under the
command of Scanderbegg's own nephew,
Hamza, whose jealousy had caused him to
betray his uncle, marched through and
devastated the Matt River Valley in
north central Albania. Because Hamza was
well acquainted with his uncle's
guerilla tactics, Scanderbe had to
improvise. Instead of hiding his vastly
outnumbered army once again barely
onetenth the size of the Muslim army in
the mountains and awaiting the opportune
moment to strike as he had done so many
times before, he divided them into many
smaller units and dispersed them in the
valleys in the woods. For 3 months, all
the Turks saw were tiny roving bands of
Albanians, none of which dared leave the
mountains and engage them. As a result,
nearly 3 months later, by late August,
the Ottomans had concluded that
Scanderbegg had become a moot point.
that he was done up with, that his men
had deserted him, and that he himself
had quit to the mountain fastness in
order to save his skin, to quote from
several sources. But just when the Turks
were most convinced that the Albanians
had lost both their leader and their
nerve, on September 2nd, 1457,
Scanderbeg, having reunited his 8,000
men, launched a lightning swift strike
under Mount Tuminishta. to loud cries
and the braaying instruments of war. He
and his cavalry and guerilla fighters
suddenly burst into the Muslim camp in a
frenzy of war. The trapped Turks were
terrified. Despite assurances from Hamza
that the Albanian army was much smaller
than it seemed, panic spread and the
Muslim army was routed on the plains of
Albuena. In what became one of the
Ottomans worst defeats, as many as
30,000 Turks were either butchered or
captured in the bloody onslaught. It's
important to note that not only Albania,
but all of Europe benefited from
Scanderbegg's stalwart defense and
perseverance, which continued until the
moment of his death some years later in
1468 when he was well in his 60s. Had
the Ottomans managed to transform
Albania into a launching pad into Italy
in 1450 instead of when they did in
1480, Muhammad II, the conqueror, would
have had 30 years, not just one, to
pursue his long cherished goal of
conquering Rome and from there
inundating Western Europe with his
hordes. that Scanderbegg was a
quintessential defender of the West was
even acknowledged by the United States
Congress in a 2005 resolution titled
quote honoring the 600th anniversary of
the birth of George Castriote Scanderbe
statesman, diplomat and military genius
for his role in saving Western Europe
from Ottoman occupation. In the
centuries following his death, more than
1,000 books in over 20 different
languages and any number of operas and
plays were written about him. In a
letter dated 1756, Major General James
Wolf of Britain wrote that Scanderbeck
quote excels all the officers, ancient
and modern, in the conduct of a small
defensive army. In 1905, historian
William J. Armstrong went so far as to
write that, quote, "The exploits, even
of the renowned paladins of the
Crusades, whether Godfrey or Tankrid or
Richard or Raymond, pale to
insignificance by similar comparison.
Only the legendary feats of King Arthur
and his knights suggest a parallel of
wondrous achievement. Today, however,
and as might be expected, virtually no
one in the West has ever heard of
Scanderbegg, one of the West's greatest
defenders against Islamic aggression.
And there's a very obvious reason for
that. To learn more about Scanderbegg,
you might want to get a copy of my book,
Defenders of the West, which has an
entire chapter, about 40 pages worth, on
the Albanian Braveheart.